Thank you for listening to The Rest Is History. For weekly bonus episodes, ad-free listening, early access to series, and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to therestishistory.com and join the club. That is therestishistory.com. Thanks for listening to The Rest Is History. For bonus episodes, early access, ad-free listening, and access to our chat community, please sign up at restishistorypod.com. Or, if you're listening on the Apple Podcasts app, you can subscribe within the app in just a few clicks. A kiss on the hand maybe quite continental But diamonds are a girl's best friend
感谢收听《The Rest Is History》。想要收听每周独家加更节目、无广告广播、抢先观看系列节目并加入我们广受欢迎的聊天社区，请访问 therestishistory.com 并加入俱乐部。网址是 therestishistory.com。感谢收听《The Rest Is History》。想要收听加更节目、抢先观看、无广告广播以及加入我们的聊天社区，请在 restishistorypod.com 注册。或者，如果您使用的是 Apple Podcasts App，只需点击几下即可在应用内订阅。亲吻手背或许相当具有欧洲大陆风情 但钻石才是女孩最好的朋友
A kiss may be grand but it won't pay the rental On your humble flat or help you at the automat. Men grow cold as girls grow old and we all lose our charms in the end. But square cut or pear shaped, these rocks don't lose their shape. Diamonds are a girl's best friend. That, Dominic Sandbrook, was, of course, Marilyn Monroe, perhaps the most iconic of all. Tom, nobody's still listening.
亲吻或许很棒 但它付不起房租 在你简陋的公寓里，也无法在自动售货机帮到你。随着女孩老去，男人变得冷漠，而我们最终都会失去魅力。但无论是方形还是梨形，这些钻石都不会变样。钻石是女孩最好的朋友。多米尼克·桑德布鲁克，那当然是玛丽莲·梦露，也许是最具标志性的一位。汤姆，已经没人听了。
There's no point talking. Nobody's still listening. I thought that was a magnificent performance. The most iconic of all Hollywood stars. I realised when I was reading up about her that she is of course the same age as the queen so if she was still alive now she'd be 96 born in 1926 yeah yeah but of course you know in in diamonds are a girl's best friend she famously says men grow cold as as girls grow old but marilyn never grew old she died when she was 36. And so she serves as a kind of undying
说话毫无意义。已经没人听了。我认为那是一场精彩绝伦的演出。所有好莱坞明星中最具标志性的一位。我读到关于她的资料时意识到，她和女王同龄，所以如果她现在还活着，她就96岁了，生于1926年，对，对。但当然，正如你在《钻石是女孩最好的朋友》中所知，她有一句名言：“随着女孩老去，男人变得冷漠”，但玛丽莲从未老去，她在36岁时就去世了。因此，她成为了一种不朽的
icon of femininity. But this is the rest is history. This is not the rest is Hollywood. So what is the justification, do you think, for doing an episode on Marilyn Monroe in a history podcast? Well, Marilyn Monroe is still very unusually for a film star whose career ended 1962 has an enormous amount of pop cultural traction even now doesn't she i mean basically the peg for us doing this is the anna de armas film the netflix film blonde based on joyce carolotes's novel which is out i think has just come out this last week on netflix and some cinemas, but also I suppose Marilyn Monroe, she's a classic example of that sort of 20th century figure who becomes an avatar for,
女性气质的偶像。但这里是《The Rest Is History》。这里不是《The Rest Is Hollywood》。那么，你认为在历史播客中制作一集关于玛丽莲·梦露的节目，其理由是什么？嗯，玛丽莲·梦露依然——对于一个职业生涯于1962年结束的电影明星来说非常罕见——即使在今天也有着巨大的流行文化吸引力，不是吗？我的意思是，我们做这个节目的契机基本上是安娜·德·阿玛斯的电影，那部基于乔伊丝·卡罗尔·奥茨同名小说、在Netflix上线的电影《金发梦露》，我想它就在上周刚刚在Netflix和一些影院上映了。但我也认为，玛丽莲·梦露是那种20世纪人物的经典代表，她成为了某种形象的化身，
for all kinds of other things. So I think she's an avatar for the classical age of Hollywood for, for a kind of innocent, well, we'll go on to talk about whether it is innocent for a sense of hedonism and a sort of pre sexual revolution kind revolution kind of pleasure-seeking. But also, of course, I think she's a symbol of 50s America, of Eisenhower's, specifically, I would say, Eisenhower's America, the Cold War, buoyant, optimistic,
各种其他事物的化身。所以我认为她是好莱坞经典时代的化身，代表着某种单纯——嗯，我们接下来会讨论它是否单纯——代表着一种享乐主义和一种前性解放时期的追求快乐。但当然，我认为她也是50年代美国的象征，特别是艾森豪威尔时期的美国，我会说是艾森豪威尔的美国，冷战时期，充满活力、乐观主义，
intensely consumerist, the world after the Second World War. I think Marilyn Monroe, the very image of her sort of kindles in people's minds, this sort of sense of, and of course, we can unpick all this, this sort of lost paradise of American dominance and of Americanization. And I think that's what she represents as much as anything, don't you? Well, except to the degree that she's also a tragic figure. So she's also, she's an embodiment of the dark side of the American dream. She's been caught up in the style of, you know, what is it, the paranoid style of politics?
极其注重消费主义，这是二战后的世界。我认为玛丽莲·梦露的形象会在人们心中唤起一种感觉，当然我们可以剖析这一切，这种对美国统治和美国化失落天堂的感觉。我认为这正是她所代表的，不亚于其他任何东西，你觉得呢？嗯，除非考虑到她同时也是一个悲剧人物。所以她也是美国梦黑暗面的化身。她卷入了那种风格的——你知道的，叫什么来着，政治的偏执风格？
What was the... Yes, Richard Hofstadter, the paranoid style in American politics. So the way in which she's become the subject of so many conspiracy theories. Absolutely. So she dies a year before JFK gets assassinated. And of course, she was involved with JFK, although to what degree is furiously debated. So she has been caught up in the snarl of all those conspiracy theories. But also, in a way, she's a kind of icon of a pre-feminist age.
什么是……是的，理查德·霍夫施塔特（Richard Hofstadter）的《美国政治中的偏执风格》。所以她成为了如此之多的阴谋论的主题。没错。因此，她在肯尼迪（JFK）遇刺前一年去世。当然，她曾与肯尼迪有过交往，尽管程度如何受到了激烈的争论。因此她卷入了所有这些阴谋论的纠葛之中。但从某种意义上说，她也是前女权主义时代的一种偶像。
But it's very, very easy to interpret her as a feminist figure, I think, both because she filings of the broader culture of America in that period. She engages with sport in the form of Joe DiMaggio, the great baseball star who she marries, with intellectual life in the form of Arthur Miller, who she then goes on to marry. Arthur Miller is embroiled in the McCarthy investigations, and Marilyn plays a quite heroic role in that, I think. She's a friend of Frank Sinatra, so there's a hint of the mafia there as well. I mean, she's, I think, a really kind of totemic figure historically. So I think, I hope we have justified doing this podcast on her. Well, she has also a dimension that you hinted at a second ago, which we, again, we can perhaps go into later, which is you talked about her suffering. So the Joyce Carol Oates book, Blonde, for example, on which the current film, the Anna
但将她诠释为一个女权主义人物其实非常非常容易，我认为，一方面是因为她与那一时期美国更广泛文化的档案（此处原文filings疑为fittings之误或录音识别偏差，意指契合/融入）相契合。她与体育界接触，对象是她嫁给的伟大棒球明星乔·迪马乔；与知识界接触，对象是她后来嫁给的亚瑟·米勒。亚瑟·米勒卷入了麦卡锡调查，我认为玛丽莲在其中扮演了相当英勇的角色。她是弗兰克·西纳特拉的朋友，所以其中也隐约带有黑手党的影子。我的意思是，我认为她在历史上是一个真正具有图腾似的人物。所以我认为，我们做这期关于她的播客是师出有名的。嗯，她还有一个你刚才暗示过的维度，我们同样可以稍后深入探讨，那就是你谈到了她的痛苦。因此，比如乔伊丝·卡罗尔·奥茨的书《金发梦露》，当前的电影——安娜
de Armas film is based, is one of a host of sort of pop cultural visions of Marilyn Monroe that casts her as a victim. And actually, whether she was a victim is worth discussing. Of course, we live now in a kind of cultural landscape in which victimhood is highly prized and indeed celebrated. But whether Marilyn Monroe, was she a victim or was she an immensely canny operator who rose from nowhere to get to the top and did so not by suffering, but by being professional, hardworking, remaking herself, all those kinds of things. I mean, that's something else that is worth debating. I think it's possible for her to have been both. I mean, I think she did have quite a traumatic life. Her upbringing was pretty rough. But more traumatic than, say, Audrey Hepburn?
·德·阿玛斯的电影就是基于这本书——它是众多将玛丽莲·梦露塑造为受害者的流行文化愿景之一。事实上，她是否是一个受害者是值得讨论的。当然，我们现在生活在这样一种文化景观中：受害者身份备受推崇甚至赞美。但玛丽莲·梦露究竟是一个受害者，还是一个极其精明的运营者——她从社会底层崛起登上顶峰，靠的不是痛苦，而是专业、努力、重塑自我以及所有这些特质？我的意思是，这也是值得争辩的。我认为她两者兼而有之是有可能的。我的意思是，我认为她确实度过了相当创伤的一生。她的成长经历相当坎坷。但比方说，比奥黛丽·赫本更具创伤吗？
Well, I think there's a kind of Dickensian quality to the role that she mythologised her upbringing. But I think it clearly did leave scars. I think she probably, I don't want to go all psychoanalytical, although Marilyn's engagement with psychoanalysis is another very, very kind of paradigmatic 1950s American thing. But I think she did have, to a degree, daddy issues, perhaps. But I know that both of us hugely admire one book in particular on Marilyn, which was very much a friend of the show, Sarah Churchwell, who did a fantastic episode with us on Gone with the Wind. And she wrote, I think it's her first book, isn't it? The Many Lives of Marilyn Monroe.
嗯，我认为她在某种程度上将自己的成长经历神话化了，带有某种狄更斯式的色彩。但我认为它显然留下了伤痕。我认为她可能——我不想陷入精神分析，尽管玛丽莲对精神分析的接触是另一个非常非常典型的50年代美国现象。但我认为她确实在某种程度上有点“恋父情结”，也许吧。但我知道我们俩都极其欣赏关于玛丽莲的一本书，作者是节目的老朋友莎拉·丘奇韦尔（Sarah Churchwell），她曾和我们一起做过一期关于《乱世佳人》的精彩节目。她写了——我想这是她的第一本书，对吧？——《玛丽莲·梦露的许多面孔》（The Many Lives of Marilyn Monroe）。
Yeah. Gone with the Wind. And she wrote, I think it's her first book, isn't it? The Many Lives of Marilyn Monroe. It's a book less about Marilyn than about how Marilyn has been understood and presented. And right in the opening page, I'll just read it. So she's talking about the death, which is obviously the most controversial and object of particular fascination. It is hardly news that Marilyn Monroe's death remains controversial. More surprisingly, the mysteries surrounding her death are not the only confusions in her story. Uncertainty is the story of Marilyn's biographical life. We don't know nearly as much about her as people may assume. Although Marilyn Monroe was one of the most famous, most photographed, most written about people in the 20th century, we know less about her for certain than about many far more distant historical figures.
嗯。《乱世佳人》。她写了——我想这是她的第一本书，对吧？——《玛丽莲·梦露的许多面孔》。这本书与其说是关于玛丽莲的，不如说是关于玛丽莲是如何被理解和呈现的。就在开篇的第一页，我读一下。她谈到了死亡，这显然是最具争议且最令人着迷的话题。玛丽莲·梦露的死至今仍充满争议，这算不上什么新闻。更令人惊奇的是，围绕她死亡的谜团并不是她故事中唯一的混淆之处。不确定性才是玛丽莲传记人生的写照。我们对她的了解远没有人们想象的那么多。尽管玛丽莲·梦露是20世纪最著名、被拍摄最多、被书写最多的人物之一，但与许多远得多的历史人物相比，我们对她的确切了解反而更少。
So I think that's absolutely true. And Sarah demonstrates it pretty conclusively in her book. But the implications of that for the study of history and biography more generally is really quite destabilizing. So we did an episode on Theodora, the circus performer who ends up marrying Justinian, the Roman emperor. And historians debate, you know, how much of the stories told in the scandalous stories told about how far are they true? But obviously, we cannot know. Because if we can't know key details about Marilyn Monroe's life, then what earthly hope do we have of ever arriving at solid ground when we study the
所以我认为这绝对是真的。莎拉在她的书中相当确凿地证明了这一点。但这对一般历史和传记研究的影响实际上是相当具有颠覆性的。因此我们曾做过一期关于狄奥多拉的节目，这位马戏表演者最终嫁给了罗马皇帝查士丁尼。历史学家们争论着，那些关于她的丑闻故事中有多少是真实的？但显然，我们无法得知。因为如果我们无法得知玛丽莲·梦露生平的关键细节，那么当我们研究诸如古代罗马女皇这样的人物生平时，我们还有什么尘世的希望能够得出坚实的结论呢？
life, say, of an ancient Roman empress. I think that's absolutely right. When I was reading Sarah Churchwell's book, I was thinking, she reflects quite often about these figures in history who we claim to know. How much do we actually really know? Or how much are we simply, she gives brilliant examples in the book of biographers who repeat other biographers who are actually repeating the original, you know, the stories kind of going around in a circle. And merely because the story is told many times, it becomes enshrined as a fact. But as she says, you know, especially with somebody who sex and romance are such an important part of their image.
我认为这绝对正确。当我读莎拉·丘奇韦尔的书时，我在想，她经常反思历史上的这些人物——我们声称了解他们。我们实际上了解多少？或者我们在多大程度上仅仅是在——她在书中给出了精彩的例子，讲到一些传记作家重复其他传记作家的话，而后者实际上又在重复最初的说法，你知道的，这些故事在一个圈子里循环。仅仅因为一个故事被讲了很多遍，它就被奉为事实。但正如她所说，特别是对于某个将性与浪漫作为其形象极其重要一部分的人来说。
But with those kinds of matters, you can never really know what happens between two people or, you know, so much of that. You talked about the Kennedy story. I mean, ultimately, the truth of the Kennedy story is nobody knows or will ever know or can ever know. So Norman Mailer, who I suppose is the kind of polar opposite of Joyce Carol Oates, he's the hard drinking misogynist. Yeah.
但对于这类事情，你永远无法真正知道两个人之间究竟发生了什么，或者诸如此类的大量细节。你谈到了肯尼迪的故事。我的意思是，归根结底，肯尼迪故事的真相是：没有人知道，也永远不会知道，更不可能知道。所以诺曼·梅勒（Norman Mailer）——我猜他算是乔伊丝·卡罗尔·奥茨的极对立面，他是那个酗酒的厌女者。对。
But he wrote obsessively about Marilyn. And he said, why not assume that Marilyn Monroe opens the entire problem of biography um Elton John and yeah that idea that Norma Jean is the real Marilyn and that Marilyn Monroe is a fake uh is is a very kind of powerful idea it's what animated Candle in the Wind and a lot of studies but But I think it's slightly more complicated than that, isn't it? I think it is more complicated because, I mean, Sarah Churchwell says in her book, you know, the classic division that biographers make is between Norma Jean, who was authentic and real, and Marilyn Monroe, who was a fake. And this was an example of kind of selling her soul and all this stuff. I mean, actually, of course, changing your name was completely common in 1940s Hollywood, wasn't it? I mean, you think of Cary Grant, you think of any number of stars. John Wayne. John Wayne, right, exactly. I mean, who...
但他对玛丽莲进行了痴迷般的书写。他说，为什么不假设玛丽莲·梦露开启了传记的整个问题呢？嗯，埃尔顿·约翰和——是的，诺玛·简是真正的玛丽莲而玛丽莲·梦露是个假货的这种想法——这是一个非常有影响力的观点，正是它激发了《风中残烛》（Candle in the Wind）和许多研究。但我认为事情比这稍微复杂一点，不是吗？我认为确实更复杂，因为，莎拉·丘奇韦尔在她的书中说过，传记作家们做出的经典划分是在真实纯粹的诺玛·简和虚假的玛丽莲·梦露之间。而这被视为出卖灵魂之类事情的一个例子。我的意思是，实际上，在1940年代的好莱坞，改名字是极其普遍的，不是吗？想想加里·格兰特，想想任何数量的明星。约翰·韦恩。约翰·韦恩，没错，正是如此。我的意思是，谁……
Yeah. I mean, John Wayne doesn't seem to have been unduly traumatized by it. No, I mean, it's absolutely... I don't think she sold her soul in changing her name, nor do I think she lost touch with her original identity or anything like that. She's born Norma Jean Mortensen, isn't she? And Mortensen is not her father. I mean, she's illegitimate. I know you're keen to psychoanalyse her. I mean, obviously you were saying that she does a sort of search for, hunt for a father. I mean, that's something I think that probably male biographers love to ascribe to her. Well, she did call all her husbands daddy. I'm just throwing that out.
对。我的意思是，约翰·韦恩似乎并没有因此受到过度的精神创伤。不，我的意思是，绝对是……我不认为她在改名时出卖了灵魂，我也不认为她与自己最初的身份失去了联系或诸如此类的事情。她出生时叫诺玛·简·莫滕森（Norma Jeane Mortensen），对吧？而莫滕森并不是她父亲的姓。我的意思是，她是私生女。我知道你热衷于对她进行精神分析。我的意思是，很显然你刚才说她在进行某种寻找父亲的追寻。我的意思是，我认为这大概是男性传记作家最喜欢归咎于她的地方。嗯，她确实把所有的丈夫都叫爸爸。我只是随口一提。
She did. But again, Tom tom who knows i know i can honestly say why that is or whether that represents uh some deep-seated lack or is it just a quirk i mean we just don't know these kinds of things it's easy it's tempting for us to speculate but i think to some degree this is a classic example of why it's sometimes actually more fruitful to resist speculation than to admit what you don't know. But what I would also say is that she presented herself in the early years of her fame as an orphan. She wasn't an orphan. Yeah. No.
她确实这么叫。但话说回来，汤姆，汤姆，谁知道呢？我知道，我可以诚实地说为什么会这样，或者这是否代表着某种根深蒂固的缺失，还是只是一种怪癖？我的意思是，我们根本不知道这些事情。我们很容易、也很诱人去进行推测，但我认为在某种程度上，这是一个经典的例子，说明有时候抵制推测、承认自己不知道的内容，实际上比盲目猜测更有成效。但我还要说的是，在她成名的早期，她把自己塑造成了一个孤儿。她并不是孤儿。是的。不。
But she might as well have been. So her mother ends up being committed. She's very mentally distressed. But her mother is called Monroe. That's her maiden name. Yes. She burns through men. So she takes on a lot of different names over the course of her life. And so that I think is, you'd say Mortensen is one of them. Baker is another. And so it goes on. But actually, in a way, Monroe is the most authentic, you know, it's a much more authentic
但她其实也差不多是了。所以她的母亲最终被送进精神病院。她精神非常痛苦。但她的母亲叫梦露。那是她娘家的姓。是的。她经历了一个又一个男人。所以在她的一生中，她用了许多不同的名字。所以我认为，你会说莫滕森是其中之一。贝克是另一个。诸如此类。但实际上，从某种程度上说，梦露是最真实的名字，你知道的，比玛丽莲被赋予的任何其他名字都要真实得多……我们很久以前做过一个关于加州的播客，汤姆，我们在那个加州播客中谈到了这种现象：来自中西部的穷苦中西部人向西迁往加州，寻找某种应许之地。我的意思是，在某种程度上，人们会从《愤怒的葡萄》之类的作品中记住那种形象。嗯，她母亲的故事就是这样。她的母亲是一个贫穷的中西部人，过着悲惨的生活，你知道的，她有着持续的精神健康问题。正如你所说，她进出各种收容所和精神病院。玛丽莲的父亲，现在人们普遍认为，是一个叫查尔斯·斯坦利·吉福德（Charles Stanley Gifford）的人。
name than any of the other names that Marilyn was given. So... We did a podcast, Tom, about California many moons ago and we were talking the california podcast about this phenomenon of people from the midwest poor midwesterners moving west to california in search kind of of the promised land i mean to some extent you know people will remember that kind of image from the greats of wrath or something well that's what her mother's story was her mother was a poor midwesterner who's had a wretched life you know, she had constant mental health troubles. As you said, she's sort of in and out of homes and asylums. Marilyn's father, I think it's now generally agreed, was somebody called Charles Stanley Gifford.
他是个视频剪辑师，对吧？电影剪辑师。没错。还有她母亲和他的那段转瞬即逝的关系。他们从来都不是，你知道的，从来都不是那种有意义的伴侣。而且我认为玛丽莲从来没有真正了解过他。玛丽莲自己就是玛丽莲。我的意思是，在这个阶段她当然叫诺玛·简。所以她出生于1926年。她在萧条时期长大。美国的经济大萧条比许多欧洲国家要糟糕得多，比英国要糟糕得多。
He was a video editor, wasn't he? Film editor. Exactly. And the sort of fleeting relationship he had with her mother. They were never, you know never a sort of meaningful couple. And Marilyn never, I think, really knew him. And Marilyn herself was Marilyn. I mean, she's called Norma Jean, of course, at this stage. So she was born in 1926. She grows up in the Depression. The Depression is far worse in the United States than it is in many European countries, much worse than it was in Britain.
所以她在那种充满紧缩、苦难等氛围的环境中长大。她和不同的寄养父母一起频繁进出各种收容所。她有一段时间甚至在孤儿院里，对吧？是的，呆了21个月。她，是的，有那种不得不一直洗碗的故事，这非常像狄更斯在鞋油厂的经历。我的意思是，这就是你对狄更斯的评价。但当然，我们通过她了解到的关于那段时期的内容，
So she grows up in a climate of kind of austerity and misery and so on. She's in and out of homes with different kind of foster parents. She's in an orphanage at one stage, isn't she? Yeah, for 21 months. And she, yeah, kind of stories about having to do all the washing up all the time, which is very like Dickens in the bathroom factory. I mean, that's what you say about the Dickens. But of course, what we know about that from her
来自于她很多很多年后接受的采访。或者是某种由他人代笔的东西。而且话说回来，要弄清楚这些非常困难，我的意思是，从几十年后讲述的故事中，你对某人的早年生活究竟了解多少？他们自己又真正了解多少？我的意思是，正如诺曼·梅勒所说，这些都是所有传记的基本问题，
comes from interviews that she gave many, many years later. Or kind of ghostwritten things. And again, it's very hard to ever get, I mean, how much do you know about somebody's early life from stories they tell decades later? How much do they really know themselves? I mean, these are all, as Norman Whaler would say, these are the fundamental questions of all biographies,
不仅仅是玛丽莲·梦露的传记。是的，其中之一，当然，核心谜团之一就是她是否曾被性虐待、性侵犯，对此同样有很多不同的解读。因为这被视为对解释她最终成为怎样的女性至关重要，人们对此进行了痴迷般的纠结。但我认为这是其中之一，你知道的，莎拉·丘奇韦尔指出我们无从得知，
not just biographies of Marilyn Monroe. Yeah, and one of them, of course, one of the key mysteries is whether she was sexually abused, sexually assaulted, on which, again, there have been many interpretations. And because it's seen as being somehow crucially important to explaining the woman that she becomes, people worry at it obsessively. But I think it's one of these things, you know, Sarah Churchill points out that we can't know,
我们就是无从得知。不，我们不能。我认为发生的事情是——因此性虐待问题是一个有趣的问题，因为它开启了两种不同的探究途径。一种观点认为玛丽莲·梦露一直是个受害者。她总是遭到男性的虐待。这显然就是乔伊丝·卡罗尔·奥茨对她的愿景，也是当今非常流行的一种愿景。另一种则是你可能会称之为稍微偏向诺曼·梅勒风格的愿景，即她的一切永远都与性有关。所以诺曼·梅勒关于她有这样一句非同寻常的话，他说：她就是救赎，是一把地道的性爱斯特拉迪瓦里小提琴，如此华丽、宽容、幽默、顺从且温柔，以至于最平庸的音乐家也会在她小提琴消融的魔力中放松他那匮乏的艺术。这种认为她从头到尾都浸润在性之中的想法。
we just can't know. No, we can't. And I think what happens with, so the sexual abuse issue is an interesting one, because it sort of opens up two different avenues of inquiry. One is the idea that Marilyn Monroe was always a victim. She was always abused by men. And that obviously is the sort of Joyce Carol Oates vision of her, a very popular vision today. The other is what you might call the sort of slightly more Norman Mailer-ish vision, which is that she's always all about sex. So Norman Mailer has this extraordinary line where he says of her, she was deliverance, a very Stradivarius of sex, so gorgeous, forgiving, humorous, compliant and tender that even the most mediocre musician would relax his lack of art
疯狂的性欲气息，这是他用来形容她的另一个词。是的，我的意思是，现在我们觉得这非常令人反感。但我的意思是，其中包含着某种真理的成分。而且她的形象显然一直都与性深度捆绑。她小时候被虐待过吗？这又是如何助长了这一点的？我的意思是，再次强调，这是一个经典的例子，这一切都只是推测，不是吗？这一切都只是
in the dissolving magic of her violin. And this sort of idea that she's steeped in sex from the first minute to the last. Insane sexual musk, it was another phrase he used about her. Yeah, I mean, that's very distasteful now to us. But I mean, there's an element of truth in it. And her image was always obviously deeply wrapped up with sex. And was she abused as a child? And how did that therefore feed into that? I mean, again, this is a classic example of, it's all speculation, isn't it? It's
来自那些以偷窥狂心态仔细斟酌她故事细节的大批作家的投射。我认为最诚实的说法是，我们其实根本连一点概念都没有。但我认为，无可争辩的是，如果你是一个没有受过太多教育、来自一连串破裂家庭的极美貌女孩，在洛杉矶游荡，在好莱坞的边缘，那里有很多贪婪、掠夺成性的男人。而玛丽莲成为了——你知道的，她是诺玛·简，
all projection from the legions of writers who have kind of voyeuristically picked over the details of her story. And I think the most honest thing to say is that we actually don't have the faintest idea. But I think also, I mean, it's indisputable that if you are a very, very beautiful girl without much education from a series of broken homes, gravitate, you know, in Los Angeles, on the margins of Hollywood, there are a lot of very rapacious, predatory men. And Marilyn became, you know, she, Norma Jean,
然后她被电影公司赋予了“玛丽莲”这个名字。这就是——这显然是她所处世界的一部分。驱动她整个职业生涯的核心动力之一，是对那种使她能够被塑造为女权主义偶像的力量的深深敌意；我想另一个原因正如你所说的那样，她其实对自己的性魅力完全毫不掩饰。你知道的，所以她以海报女郎（pin-up）的身份开始她的职业生涯，对吧？没错。是的。所以海报女郎当时算是一个相当新鲜的事物。其实也就几十年的历史。我的意思是，在二战期间显然极其受欢迎。因此，对于美国人来说，他们会——你知道的，你的兵营里会贴着海报。
and then she gets given the name Marilyn by studios. That is, that's clearly part of the world that she was in. And one of the animating things that drives her throughout her career is a deep sense of hostility to the kind of the power that enable her to be cast as a feminist icon. And I guess another would be exactly what you were saying, that she's actually completely unapologetic about her own sexuality. You know, so she begins her career as a pinup, doesn't she? That's right. Yeah. So pinups are quite a new thing. A couple of decades old, really. I mean, obviously hugely popular in World War II. So for American, they will, you know, you'll have pinups in your barracks.
人们会在飞机的机尾上、飞机的各个部件上画上豆蔻年华的年轻女孩，诸如此类。她就是这样开始的，不是吗？但此外，还有一个与战争的联系，不是吗？因为她是通过在一家——她在哪里工作来着？一家军工厂——哦对，洛杉矶的一家军工厂工作时被拍照而进入海报女郎行业的。她很年轻就结婚了，我想大概是在她16岁生日三周后，她的丈夫应征入伍并去了海外。他们俩都深度参与了第二次世界大战。丈夫是一名士兵，她在
People will paint nubile young girls on the tails of their, on bits of their planes and things like that. And that's how she makes a start, isn't it? But also there's another war connection, isn there because she's she gets into the sort of the pin-up business through being photographed when she's working in a what's she a munitions factory yeah munitions factory in los angeles and she she's married very young i think kind of three weeks after her 16th birthday and her husband is drafted and goes abroad. Both of them are kind of very much involved in the Second World War. The husband is a soldier, she's working in a
军工厂工作，正是在那里她被星探发现了。所以她对海报女郎的身份并不感到羞愧。而且有趣的是，她还拍摄了裸照。随着时间的推移，这成了一场巨大的丑闻，因为当她成为明星后，这些照片公之于众，而她并没有否认，而是（你知道的）对此没有做任何形式的道歉。是的，我的意思是，实际上……当一个海报女郎并没有什么可耻的。因此，上世纪30年代末和40年代的两位大牌海报女郎——丽塔·海华斯（Rita Hayworth）和贝蒂·格拉布尔（Betty Grable）——从某种意义上说，她们并不是不体面的公众人物。她们是极受欢迎的明星，不仅在美国，在全世界都广为人知。这显然就是玛丽莲的野心。她认为自己可以成为
munitions factory, and that's where she gets kind of talent spotted. And so she's unapologetic about the pinups. But also, interestingly, she gets photographed nude. And in due course, this becomes a great scandal, because when she's become a star you know the knowledge of these photographs become public and again rather than denying it she's you know she makes no apologies for it whatsoever yeah i mean i think actually uh there's no disgrace in being a pin-up girl so the two big pin-ups of the late 1930s and 1940s rita hayworth and betty grable i mean in way, they're not unrespectable figures. They're enormously popular kind of stars recognized not just in the United States, but all over the world. And that clearly is Marilyn's ambition. She thinks that she can be
一个海报女郎，她可以像她们一样成为电影明星、性感象征。也就是在那时，她开始做一些事情，比如她拉直了头发。她把头发染成金色。现在，传记作家们再次把她染金发视为某种浮士德式的交易。对。你知道的，她失去了与自身纯粹真实性的联系。但当然，成千上万的女性正是在这个精确的时间点做着同样的事情，因为她们想成为海报女郎，或者因为她们想闯入好莱坞，
a pinup, she can be a film star as they are a sex symbol. And that's when she starts doing things like she straightens her hair. She dyes her hair blonde. Now, again, biographers have sort of taken the dyeing of her hair blonde as this sort of Faustian bargain. Yeah. You know, she's lost touch with her authenticity. But of course, there are thousands upon thousands of women who are doing this at precisely this time because they want to become pinups or because they want to break into Hollywood
或者诸如此类。我的意思是，实际上让她与众不同的并不是她的不真实或诸如此类的事。改个名字、换个发型是完全标准的操作。我认为真正不同的是她工作得如此努力。她比大多数人都要努力。她非常非常专业，并且在这个世界的框架之内，
or whatever. I mean, what distinguishes her actually is not the fact that she's inauthentic or anything like that. Having a new name, having a new sort of hairdo is completely standard. I think it's that she works so hard. She's harder working than most. She's very, very professional and she's within the sort of boundaries of that world. she is smart. And she, you know, photographers say she's always looking to try and, you know, find the right angle. Yeah. She works harder than others, you know, all of those kinds of things.
她是聪明的。而且，你知道的，摄影师们说她总是设法去寻找，你知道的，找到正确的角度。是的。她比其他人更努力，你知道的，所有这些事情。
Well, again and again, when you read about people who either photographed Marilyn or filmed her, they say there seemed to be nothing particularly impressive about her. And often they'll say she's quite chaotic. You think how on earth has she made it this way? And then they look at the rushes or they look at the stills and they say, she is just transcendently wonderful. There's a kind of amazing quote from Eve Arnold, who was the first woman to join,
好吧，一次又一次，当你读到那些给玛丽莲拍照或拍电影的人的言论时，他们会说，她似乎没有什么特别令人印象深刻的地方。他们经常会说她相当混乱。你会想，她到底是怎么走到这一步的。然后他们看毛片（未剪辑素材）或剧照，就会说，她简直是超凡脱俗的美好。伊芙·阿诺德（Eve Arnold）有一句惊人的名言，她第一位加入——
I think the Magnum Photos Agency. So, you know, a woman who really knew what she was talking about. And she said that she never knew anyone who even came close to Marilyn in natural ability to use both photographer and still camera. And clearly it's Marilyn's ability to appear on film that again, I guess, makes her a kind of archetypal figure that in a way she's exploiting the reach of this new technology in a way that no one else can quite equal and quite rival? Well, I mean, that's an interesting one. Can anybody else equal it? I mean, there had been big stars before. I mentioned two of them, Rita Hayworth and Betty Grable. There would be other
我想是马格南图片社（Magnum Photos Agency）的女性。所以，你知道的，这是一个真正知道自己在说什么的女性。她说，她从未见过任何人能在自然运用摄影师和静态相机方面哪怕接近玛丽莲。显然，玛丽莲在电影中亮相的能力——我想这也是为什么她成为了一种典型人物，从某种程度上说，她正在以一种无与伦比、无人能及的方式利用这项新技术的传播范围？嗯，这是一个有趣的问题。别人能匹敌吗？我的意思是，之前也有过大明星。我提到了其中两位，丽塔·海华斯和贝蒂·格拉布尔。在20世纪50年代还会有其他
big stars in the 1950s. I think other people do rival it. And actually, when you look at the sort of, they would do huge surveys of exhibitors, of the people who ran cinemas to see who were the biggest stars, who were the people who actually cinemas to see who were the biggest stars, who were the people who actually got people through the doors. Marilyn Monroe was never higher than fifth, and she only actually appears in the top 10 in two years, 1953 and 1954. So I think she was equaled in a sort of purely cinematic sort of capacity. But I think what makes her different is that she symbolizes more than anybody else, two elements of sort of womanhood that people are looking for in the 1940s during World War II, and then in the transition to kind of Eisenhower era
大明星。我认为其他人确实可以匹敌。事实上，当你看看那种——他们会对影院经营者进行大规模调查，看看谁是最大的明星，谁是那些真正能把观众吸引进电影院的人。玛丽莲·梦露的排名从未高过第五，而且她实际上只在两年内（1953年和1954年）进入过前十名。所以我认为她在纯粹的电影票房号召力上并不是独一无二的。但我认为让她与众不同的是，她比任何人都更能象征人们在1940年代二战期间，以及随后向艾森豪威尔时代繁荣过渡时期所寻找的女性特质的两个要素。
affluence. And they are a kind of sexual availability and a kind of voluptuousness and stuff. And the other is a kind of innocent girlishness. And obviously, you don't have to be a sort of brain surgeon to be able to locate those to the anxieties that are afflicting people in an era of wartime and dislocation and instability and so on. That men who are separated from their wives, from their families, are kind of craving an idealized kind of girlish but sexually available sort of fantasy figure, don't you think? Yeah, absolutely. But I do also think that the degree to which she remains to this day an icon, far more than any other female or indeed male actor from the period, is due reflection of her ability to look good on film. And I think that that's a quality that has enabled her image to be reproduced. And it's also why she's a key figure, not just in film, not just in magazines, but also in advertising, isn't she?
一个是某种性方面的易得性、某种丰满感之类的东西。另一个是某种天真烂漫的少女感。显然，你不需要成为一个脑外科医生就能将这些特质与饱受战时、流离失所和不稳定等焦虑折磨的人们的心理联系起来。那些与妻子、家人分离的男人们，正在渴望一种理想化的、少女般但又在性方面可接近的幻想人物，你不觉得吗？是的，绝对是的。但我同样认为，她之所以至今仍是一个偶像——远超那个时期的任何其他女演员甚至男演员——很大程度上归功于她在电影中上镜的能力。我认为正是这种特质使她的形象得以被不断复制。这也是为什么她不仅在电影中、在杂志中，而且在广告中也是一个关键人物，不是吗？
So as she does now, so back then, she could sell things to a ferocious degree. So I guess the most famous photo of her is dabbing Chanel No. 5, isn't it, on herself? Chanel, exactly. The fact that she's – well, the pin-up itself is a kind of consumerist – you know, it's a product, right? I mean, you buy pin-ups, you get them in magazines and so on. She's always kind of implicated in the world,
所以就像她现在这样，在当时，她也能以惊人的程度推销商品。所以我想她最著名的照片就是把香奈儿5号（Chanel No. 5）涂在自己身上，对吧？香奈儿，正是如此。事实上，她——好吧，海报本身就是一种消费主义的产物——你知道的，它是一种商品，对吧？我的意思是，你购买海报，你在杂志等地方看到它们。她总是与这个世界交织在一起，
in the sort of booming world of American consumerism. And I do think that it's not just that she's advertising the product, but, of course, she is also the product. Well, I mean, yeah. So the seediest manifestation of that is that the nude photos for which she got paid $50 or something, they get bought by Hugh Hefner. He buys the negatives for $500. He slaps them all over Playboy and he makes millions from them.
与蓬勃发展的美国消费主义世界交织在一起。而且我确实认为，她不仅是在宣传产品，当然，她自己也是产品。嗯，好吧。因此，其中最龌龊的表现是，她因拍摄裸照只拿到了50美元左右的报酬，这些照片却被休·海夫纳（Hugh Hefner）买下了。他以500美元买下了底片，把它们大肆刊登在《花花公子》上，并因此赚取了数百万美元。
So there's a story. Yeah. As we go towards the break, let's just get her into Hollywood, Tom. Yeah, so let's not end on that note. Yes, so she separates from her first husband, divorces him. Yeah.
所以有个故事。是的，在我们进入中场休息之前，汤姆，让我们先把她带入好莱坞吧。好的，那我们别以那个调子结束。是的，所以她与第一任丈夫分居、离婚。是的。
She gets picked up by a range of talent agents, directors who recognize her talent. She starts to appear in major films. So Gentlemen Prefer Blondes, which features the song that I impersonated so magnificently at the start of this episode. So, 1953 is really the year. She's done a few films in the early 50s, but 53, she did Niagara, Gentlemen Prefer Blondes, and How to Marry a Millionaire. And I guess it's the combination of those three, isn't it? Because that's the first year, 53, in which she appears in this top 10 for the exhibitors.
她被一系列发掘她才华的星探和导演看中。她开始出演重要电影。因此，《绅士爱美人》（Gentlemen Prefer Blondes）就包含了我在本集节目开头模仿得如此精彩的那首歌。所以，1953年真的是关键的一年。她在50年代初拍过几部电影，但在53年，她拍了《尼亚加拉》（Niagara）、《绅士爱美人》和《如何嫁给一个百万富翁》（How to Marry a Millionaire）。我想正是这三部电影的结合，对吧？因为那是她第一年（53年）进入影院经营者评选的前十名。
And this poll based on, you know, who are the big stars of the day? So she's not as big, actually, as, you know, John Wayne or Gary Cooper. And she's not perhaps as... She doesn't have the prestige, nothing like the prestige of a Catherine Hepburn or somebody. But she would get people through the doors, I think, by the end of 1953 in a way that she wouldn't have done a couple of years earlier. And then it's the events that happen after that kind of leverage her to become more than just a film star and make her a cultural icon. So when we come back after the break, perhaps we'll look at that. We'll look at Joe DiMaggio, Arthur Miller, and the Kennedys.
这项民意调查基于（你知道的）谁是当天的超级巨星？所以实际上她的名气没有约翰·韦恩或加里·库珀那么大。她也许也没有……她没有凯瑟琳·赫本那样的声望，完全没有那种声望。但在1953年底，她吸引观众走进影院的能力是几年前所无法企及的。然后，在此之后发生的事情将她推波助澜，使她不仅仅是一个电影明星，更成为一个文化偶像。所以当我们中场休息回来后，也许我们会探讨这一点。我们将看看乔·迪马乔、亚瑟·米勒和肯尼迪家族。
Very good. We'll see you after the break. I'm Marina Hyde. And I'm Richard Osman. And together we host The Rest Is Entertainment. It's your weekly fix of entertainment news, reviews, splash of showbiz gossip. And on our Q&A,
很好。我们中场休息后见。我是玛丽娜·海德。我是理查德·奥斯曼。我们共同主持《The Rest Is Entertainment》。这里有你每周必看的娱乐新闻、评论以及少许的八盒秘闻。在我们的问答环节中，
we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works. We have just launched our Members Club. If you want ad-free listening, bonus episodes, and early access to live tickets, head to therestisentertainment.com. That's therestis rest is entertainment.com that's the rest is entertainment.com welcome back to the rest is history we're talking about marilyn monroe and tom
我们拉开娱乐业的帷幕，告诉你这一切是如何运作的。我们刚刚启动了我们的会员俱乐部。如果你想要无广告收听、加更节目以及提前获取现场门票，请前往 therestisentertainment.com。网址是 therestisentertainment.com，也就是 therestisentertainment.com。欢迎回到《The Rest Is History》，我们在谈论玛丽莲·梦露。汤姆，
you were saying so marilyn monroe is a film star by 1953 having started out as a pin-up but you were saying that it's that it's her associations that make her more than just a film star so the first is is joe dimaggio who she marries in january 1954 so joe dimaggio i mean he's a great baseball star isn't he and as a cricketer yourself you'll know presumably know all about this um of this this version of rounders that is popular in america he uh star star of the new York Yankees, Dominic. Yeah, I don't really follow baseball myself, Tom. No, but I mean, he's a hugely significant figure within baseball.
你刚才说玛丽莲·梦露在1953年通过海报女郎起家后已成为一名电影明星，但你说正是她的各种交往让她超越了普通电影明星的范畴。所以第一个交往对象是乔·迪马乔，她于1954年1月嫁给了他。那么乔·迪马乔，我的意思是他是伟大的棒球明星，对吧？作为板球迷的你，想必对这个在美国广受欢迎的“击球跑垒”游戏（指棒球）非常了解。他是纽约洋基队的明星，多米尼克。是的，我自己其实不太关注棒球，汤姆。不，我的意思是，他在棒球界是一个极其重要的人物。
I mean, kind of massive, massive star. And his presumption when he, I mean, he falls very, very deeply in love with Marilyn. She loves him clearly. And I think always she's looking she seems to be looking for emotional rather than financial support would you say that's fair i mean she's although she plays gold diggers in you know in a whole number of films she clearly wasn't a gold digger um that wasn't what she was about and joe dimaggio is a very very sober, conservative figure, really. And so perhaps embodied, again, I'm kind of veering into
我的意思是，绝对是那种超级巨星。当他——我的意思是，他深深地爱上了玛丽莲。她显然也很爱他。而且我认为她一直在寻找——她似乎在寻找情感上的支持，而不是经济上的支持，你觉得这样说公平吗？我的意思是，尽管她在许多电影中扮演淘金者，但她显然不是个淘金者，那不是她的本意。而乔·迪马乔是一个非常非常清醒、保守的人物。所以也许他体现了——再次声明，我有点滑向了
the psychoanalysis, it's almost impossible to avoid when talking about Marilyn, but perhaps she embodied a measure of solidity that she'd always been looking for. But the problem is that it begins to dawn on you that actually Marilyn is becoming a star that is putting his own fame slightly in the shadow. So they go on a tour to Japan where Joe DiMaggio is going to be doing some coaching. And she gets completely mobbed when they land in Tokyo. And at the press conference, it's all about her. It's not about DiMaggio. So you can see he's getting slightly cross about that. And then this is the time of the Korean War. And so Marilyn volunteers to go and entertain the troops in Korea, which she does brilliantly
精神分析，这在谈论玛丽莲时几乎是无法避免的——也许他体现了她一直在寻找的那种稳固感。但问题是，人们开始意识到，实际上玛丽莲正在成为一个明星，她的光芒让他的名气稍微黯然失色了。因此他们去日本旅行，乔·迪马乔将在那里进行一些执教活动。当他们在东京降落时，她被人群围得水泄不通。在记者招待会上，全都是关于她的。根本不是关于迪马乔的。所以你能看出他对此有点生气。当时正值朝鲜战争期间，玛丽莲自愿去朝鲜慰问部队，她做得非常出色，
because she, you said she's incredibly hardworking. I also think she's just a very lovable person. People love her and the troops adore her. And she comes back and she tells her husband, you have no idea what it's like to hear people cheering for you. That's right, yes. And he says, yes, I do. He thinks clearly that he, I mean, he's an old fashioned kind of Italian,
因为正如你所说，她极其努力。我也认为她只是一个非常讨人喜欢的人。人们喜欢她，部队对她崇拜有加。她回来后告诉丈夫：“你根本不知道听到人们为你欢呼是什么感觉。”没错，是的。他说：“不，我知道。”他显然认为自己——我的意思是，他是一个老派的意大利人，
slightly conservative Italian American kind of blue collar guy, isn't he, Jody Maggio? Each of them, I think, thinks of the other as a, it's too harsh to say a sort of trophy spouse but there's an element of that she's the absolute you know the the stunning hollywood starlet that is now his wife from her point of view he is the sort of strong silent as you said the sort of enormously successful sports star and she knew nothing about sport she she knew nothing about she'd basically never heard of him so both of them are slightly challenged i think by the other's fame i mean the most famous
稍微有些保守的意裔美国蓝领阶层，对吧，乔·迪马乔？我认为他们俩都把对方视为一种——说“战利品配偶”可能有点过分，但其中确实有这种成分。她是如今成为他妻子的绝对令人惊艳的好莱坞明星；从她的角度来看，他是那种沉默寡言、正如你所说的那样极其成功的体育明星。而她对体育一无所知，她对——她基本上从未听说过他。所以他们俩都因对方的名气而受到了些许挑战。我的意思是，最著名的一个
story about the two of them is that uh he's watching in absolute you know in a state of utter fury while she is being photographed in that or filmed in that enormously famous scene that they use to promote the seven-year itch when she's standing on the grating in Manhattan and the wind is blowing up her skirt. I have visited the very spot, Dominic. Have you? The last time I was in New York, I went and saw it. Yeah. And as gratings go, did it delight you?
关于他们俩的故事是：当她在曼哈顿的通风口上、风吹起她的裙子时——那是他们用来宣传《七年之痒》的那个极其著名的场景，她正在被拍照或拍摄——而他在一旁处于极度愤怒的状态。我去过那个地方，多米尼克。你去过吗？我上次去纽约时，特地去看过。是的。就通风口而言，它让你感到高兴吗？
It was a great grate. Very good. Yeah, but he doesn't like this at all, Jodie Maggio, does he? I mean, there are loads of people watching and he hates the idea of his wife being a kind of, you know, a fantasy for all these other people and a willing fantasy, I suppose. That's what he dislikes about it. And if he's objecting to that, then, I mean, in a way, it's his worst nightmare because, of course, that image, it's the photo shoot not really the film i mean it's a key part of the film but in a sense the fame of that image has been divorced from the
那是个相当棒的通风口。非常好。是的，但是乔·迪马乔一点也不喜欢这样，不是吗？我的意思是，有成群的人在看，他讨厌自己的妻子成为所有这些人的某种幻想——而且还是一个心甘情愿的幻想，我想这正是他所反感的。如果他对此提出异议，那么从某种意义上说，这是他最可怕的噩梦。因为那个形象——其实是照片拍摄而非电影本身（尽管这是电影的关键部分）——从某种意义上说，那个形象的名气已经与
seven-year-age i watched the seven-year-age a couple of nights ago and it doesn't stand up it's a pretty terrible true of just to break off from the chronology isn't that one of the peculiar things about marilyn monroe that most of her films are barely watched today, that she has an afterlife that the films don't. Some Like It Hot, I think, is still watched. Some Like It Hot, I agree with you, is still watched. But do people watch Gentlemen Prefer Blondes? Do they watch Niagara? Do they watch The Misfits? Do they watch Bus Stop? I would say the answer to all those questions is a very, very firm no. And it's a weird thing that everybody recognizes Marilyn Monroe,
《七年之痒》这部电影本身脱节了。我前几天晚上看了《七年之痒》，它经不起推敲，是一部相当糟糕的电影。顺便打断一下时间线，玛丽莲·梦露的一个奇怪之处不正在于此吗？她的绝大多数电影在今天几乎无人问观，她拥有电影所没有的来世生命。我认为《热情如火》（Some Like It Hot）依然有人看。我同意你的看法，《热情如火》依然有人看。但人们还会看《绅士爱美人》吗？会看《尼亚加拉》吗？会看《乱点鸳鸯谱》（The Misfits）吗？会看《巴士站》（Bus Stop）吗？我认为对所有这些问题的回答都是一个非常非常坚定的“不”。这是一件很诡异的事：每个人都认得玛丽莲·梦露，
but probably of those people who recognize her, 90% have never seen and will never see one of her films. I mean, she's not appearing in absolutely sort of – the films she's appearing in are not top, top films, are they? They're not films that win Academy Awards in the 1950s. They're not necessarily box office sort of chart-topping films. She has a persona that goes well beyond the appeal of an individual picture i would say but again i think it's going back to what eve arnold said about about her ability to use a photograph to use you know the the synergy
但认出她的人里面，大概90%的人从没看过、也永远不会看她的电影。我的意思是，她并没有演那种绝对算得上——她演的电影根本不是那种顶级大片，对吧？不是那种在20世纪50年代赢得奥斯卡奖的电影。也不一定是那种票房排行榜名列前茅的电影。我觉得她的个人魅力远远超越了一部具体电影的吸引力，但话说回来，我觉得这还是要回到伊芙·阿诺德（Eve Arnold）说过的话，关于她善于利用一张照片、利用那种协同作用——
between photograph and her image and her understanding of how how to make it work because that image is probably i i mean i would say that's the most famous image from a film would you say yeah i mean i can't think of anything more iconic of her with her skirt yeah it's one of the yeah i suppose it's one of the most famous but again what's that what does that image represent it's a kind of hedonism and available sexual availability it's it's new york as well i think it's new york but there's also a kind of hedonism and sexual availability. It's New York as well, I think. It's New York, but there's also a kind of innocence to it, but it's all obviously from a very, you know,
照片和她形象之间的协同作用，以及她对如何让这种效果发挥作用的理解，因为那个形象可能——我的意思是，我会说那是电影中最著名的形象，你会这么认为吗？是的，我的意思是，我想不出比这更具标志性的了，她和她的裙子，是的，这是其中一个——是的，我想这是最著名的形象之一，但话说回来，那个形象代表了什么？那是一种享乐主义和触手可及的性吸引力，它也是纽约，我觉得这就是纽约，但其中也有一种纯真，但这一切显然都来自一个非常——
it's men who like that image, isn't it? I mean, I don't think women sort of line up to have a look at that grating. I think it's men who are titillated by it. Are you saying that I only went to the grate because I was titillated? Not at all, Dominic. It was a tour of midtown New York,
那是喜欢那个形象的男人们的视角，对吧？我的意思是，我觉得女人们不会排着队去看那个通风口。我觉得那是让男人们感到兴奋的画面。你是说我去那个通风口只是因为我被挑逗了吗？完全不是，多米尼克。那是曼哈顿中城之旅，
and it was mentioned, so I was titillated. Not at all, Dominic. It was a tour of midtown New York, and it was mentioned, so I went to see it. Tom, frankly, it makes a refreshingly red-blooded change from the tours of Roman walls in car parks, obscure pilgrimage sites, all these kinds of things. It gladdens my heart to hear that you're doing these kinds of tours as well. So talking of the the marriage of beauty and etiolated intellect of course yes she she um so she separates from jojo maggio very much like the dynamic in this podcast tom to be honest she separates she separates from jojo maggio yeah and her she she um she has a bust up with the studios in in um hollywood who have basically been ripping her off and she makes a point she essentially she goes to new york and she pursues interests that she'd never before had the opportunity to pursue so she she wants to become a
而且有人提到了，所以我才被挑逗的。完全不是，多米尼克。那是曼哈顿中城之旅，既然提到了，我就去看看。说实话，汤姆，这跟去停车场参观罗马古城墙、冷门的朝圣地这些相比，让人有一种耳目一新、充满热血的转变。听到你也在进行这种类型的旅行，我感到十分欣慰。那么说到美貌与消瘦智力的结合，当然是的，她——她嗯——所以她和乔·迪马吉奥分居了，这真的很像这个播客里的动态，汤姆，说实话，她分居了，她和乔·迪马吉奥分居了，是的，而且她——她嗯——她和好莱坞的电影公司闹翻了，这些公司基本上一直在剥削她，她明确表示，她基本上去了纽约，去追求她以前从未有机会追求的兴趣，所以她——她想成为一个
better actress i think she's a brilliant actress but she wants she she's always kind of crippled by a sense of insecurity um and so she she takes up method acting but she wants, she, she's always kind of crippled by a sense of insecurity. Um, and so she, she takes up method acting, uh, she takes up psychoanalysis. So these are all absolutely kind of archetypal fifties, New York intellectual pursuits. And it's there that she really starts to get on well with the great playwright of his day, the playwright, Arthur Miller. Um, and they end up together, uh, and it generates one of the great playwright of his day, the playwright Arthur Miller, and they end up together. And it generates one of the great headlines, Egghead Marries Hourglass. Yes.
更好的演员，我觉得她是个出色的演员，但她总是——她总是被一种不安全感所折磨，嗯，所以她——她开始学习方法演技，但她想要，她，她总是被一种不安全感所折磨。嗯，所以她，她开始学习方法演技，呃，她开始进行精神分析。所以这些绝对都是50年代纽约知识分子那种典型的人生追求。正是在那里，她真正开始和当时伟大的剧作家、剧作家阿瑟·米勒（Arthur Miller）相处得很好。嗯，他们最终走到了一起，呃，这催生了——当时的伟大剧作家、剧作家阿瑟·米勒，他们最终走到了一起。这催生了其中一个最棒的新闻标题：“饱学之士迎娶性感尤物”。是的。
But it's, so her marriage to Arthur Miller, though, and Dominic, you'll know much more about this than me, embroils her in the anxiety on the part of particularly the Republicans about communist, supposed communist infiltration into Hollywood. And one of the reasons that I guess that Marilyn gravitates towards JFK rather than say to Richard Nixon is that Nixon had been particularly involved with that, hadn't he?
但这是——所以她与阿瑟·米勒的婚姻，多米尼克，你对这个的了解肯定比我多得多，把她卷入了尤其是共和党人对于共产主义、所谓共产主义对好莱坞渗透的焦虑之中。我猜玛丽莲之所以倾向于约翰·F·肯尼迪（JFK）而不是理查德·尼克松（Richard Nixon），原因之一就是尼克松曾经特别卷入其中，对吧？
Well, I'm not sure there's an alternative reality in which maybe there is. I mean, what a fantastic, fantastic fantasy that would be, which Marilyn Monroe has a relationship with Richard Nixon, one of the great lost couples of the 20th century. Yeah. So Arthur Miller, I mean, by far his most famous plays, Death of a Salesman, 1949, The Crucible, 1953. So he's already written his greatest works. And as you say, he is largely because of The crucible. He's identified with the sort of anti-McCarthyist, so the McCarthyist movement, the kind of the witch hunts, the red scares, the belief that America is being betrayed and sold out by communist subversives.
嗯，我不确定是否存在某种平行现实，也许吧。我的意思是，那将是一个多么奇妙、多么精彩的幻想啊，玛丽莲·梦露与理查德·尼克松谈恋爱，20世纪失落的伟大情侣之一。是的。所以阿瑟·米勒，我的意思是，他最著名的戏剧莫过于《推销员之死》（1949年）和《萨勒姆的女巫》（1953年）。所以他最伟大的作品已经写完了。正如你所说，很大程度上是因为《萨勒姆的女巫》，他被贴上了反麦卡锡主义的标签，也就是麦卡锡主义运动、那种猎巫行动、红色恐慌，即坚信美国正在遭到共产主义颠覆分子的背叛和出卖。
By the time she marries him, actually, McCarthyism has kind of passed its peak. So it's a little bit safer than it would have been four or five years earlier. It's still courageous, isn't it, that she stands by him at a time when people's careers are being cancelled? Or, you know, at least, I mean, she must have had the anxiety that it might have been. I think it reflects very well on her. I suppose so. I think you're enormously sort of, you're very keen on Marilyn Monroe. I know, Tom, so I don't want to say anything that will dampen your ardour. Please don't ruin it for me.
到她和他结婚时，实际上麦卡锡主义已经有点过了巅峰期。所以比四五年前要安全一些。这依然很有勇气，对吧，在人们的职业生涯纷纷被封杀的时候，她依然坚守在他身边？或者说，至少——她肯定也焦虑过可能会被封杀。我觉得这非常能体现她的优秀。大概吧。我觉得你太——你非常喜欢玛丽莲·梦露。我知道，汤姆，所以我不想说任何会浇灭你热情的话。请别毁了我的兴致。
I don't think he is under any serious threat in the sort of, what is it, 1956 they get married? Yeah, but he doesn't have to be under serious threat for both of them to think that he is under threat. I suppose so. I mean, i think you're i think you're slightly exaggerating it to be honest i mean he's a hugely popular and respected figure in kind of new york intellectual circles the the great heat of mccarthyism has largely faded okay but fine what she is doing i'll i'll throw a swap to you she is identifying herself i suppose with um a particular american subculture in the mid-1950s yeah i mean he is you know he's jewish uh he's very much a kind of new york intellectual
我觉得他在某种程度上并没有受到什么严重的威胁，那是——他们是什么时候结婚的，1956年？是的，但并不需要真正受到严重威胁，他们两个才会觉得受到了威胁。我想是的。我的意思是，我觉得你——老实说，你有点夸大了，我的意思是，他在纽约知识分子圈子里是一个非常受欢迎和受尊敬的人物，麦卡锡主义的高潮已经基本消退了。好吧，不过没关系，我向你抛出一个观点，她当时正在做的是——我猜她正在认同——嗯，20世纪50年代中期的一种特定的美国亚文化。是的，我的意思是，他——你知道，他是犹太人，呃，他非常符合那种纽约知识分子
kind of figure he moves in circles that are utterly different from those that she knew in los angeles in the kind of pit so in the pinup world or indeed the film world so she is sort of i mean to some extent this is part of her sort of crusade of self-improvement isn't it they're doing the psychoanalysis yeah doing the method acting with lee strasberg hanging around with arthur miller and his sort of boffin friends reading dostoevsky and ulysses exactly all of this sort of stuff this is all about this is all part of her upward trajectory people did sneer at it at the time and they laughed at it and they said oh this this this sort of thick dumb blonde but she was never thick she was incredibly smart no and i don't think it's just um my my devotion to marilyn making me say that i mean you can see she's a very very witty
的形象，他混迹的圈子与她在洛杉矶那种底层、也就是挂历女郎世界或电影世界里所认识的圈子完全不同。所以她有点——也就是说，在某种程度上，这也是她自我完善运动的一部分，对吧？他们一起做精神分析，是的，跟李·斯特拉斯堡（Lee Strasberg）学习方法演技，跟阿瑟·米勒和他的书呆子朋友们混在一起，阅读陀思妥耶夫斯基和《尤利西斯》，完全是诸如此类的事情。这全都是关于——这全都是她向上攀登轨迹的一部分。当时人们确实对之冷嘲热讽，他们嘲笑她，说“哦，这个——这个愚蠢的金发笨蛋”，但她从来不笨，她聪明得难以置信。不，而且我不认为这仅仅是因为——我对玛丽莲的迷恋才让我这么说，我的意思是，你可以看出她是一个非常、非常机智的
woman and well i mean she's not incredibly smart tom i mean she's she's quite smart she's she's smart and her understanding of the dynamics of the world that she's in is is very very clear so why shouldn't she enjoy dostoevsky well i think that's fine i think there is there's probably a middle ground so i think is it john houston who said of her... Yeah, he thought she was quite smart. The great director, John Huston, he said on the other hand, he said she was tremendously pretentious. She had done a lot of shit-ass studying in New York,
女性，而且——我的意思是她并不是聪明得难以置信，汤姆，我的意思是她挺聪明的，她很聪明，而且她对她所处的世界的动态的理解是非常、非常清晰的。所以她为什么就不能享受陀思妥耶夫斯基呢？好吧，我觉得这没问题，我觉得这可能有一个折中点，所以我觉得——是约翰·休斯顿（John Huston）对她评价说……是的，他觉得她挺聪明的。伟大的导演约翰·休斯顿，另一方面他说，她说她极其矫揉造作。她在纽约做过很多狗屁不通的学习，
but she acted as if she never understood why she was funny, and that was precisely what made her so funny. Yeah, but Dominic, this is for the same reason you don't like John Lennon. Very similar trajectory, going off to New York, being pretentious. No, I think there's a – I wouldn't put her in the same basket as Lennon, Tom.
但她表现得好像永远不明白自己为什么好笑，而这恰恰是她那么滑稽的原因。是的，但多米尼克，这就像你不喜欢约翰·列农（John Lennon）是同一个道理。轨迹非常相似，去纽约，表现得矫揉造作。不，我觉得有一个——我不会把她和列农归为一类，汤姆。
I mean, I wouldn't do that. Anyway, listen. I mean, by my standards, that is – High praise indeed, yes. Very high praise. So anyway, she returns to – oh, she has a disaster trip to England. She goes to London toon to um the prince and the showgirl with lawrence olivier so it's a terrorist erratic and play and olivier absolutely
我的意思是，我不会这么做。总之，听着。我的意思是，按我的标准，那是——确实是极高的赞誉，是的。极高的赞誉。所以无论如何，她回到了——哦，她去英国的旅行简直是一场灾难。她去伦敦出演——嗯，和劳伦斯·奥利维尔（Laurence Olivier）合作《游龙戏凤》，所以这是一部非常反复无常的戏剧，而奥利维尔绝对
despises her doesn't he let's be honest i mean he he has no time for it at all yes he is sexy dear marilyn he doesn't have any time for method acting olivier um as he famously said to dustin hoffman dustin hoffman was doing marathon man him and explaining how he ran marathons all the time and he did all this to practice for it and all this. And he got into the character and Olivier supposedly said to him, my dear boy, have you never thought of acting? I don't think it's Marilyn's method acting that annoys him. I think it's the slight quality of the chaotic that he finds infuriating. But again, it's this kind of magic that she has that when they, again, when they look at the rushes
看不起她，不是吗？说实话，我的意思是，他根本容不下她。是的，“亲爱的玛丽莲，性感迷人的玛丽莲”，他根本无法接受方法演技。奥利维尔——正如他对达斯汀·霍夫曼（Dustin Hoffman）所说的那样，当时达斯汀·霍夫曼正在拍《马拉松人》，向他解释自己是如何一直在跑马拉松，他做这一切是为了排练。他完全进入了角色。奥利维尔据说对他说：“我亲爱的孩子，你从来没想过要演戏吗？”我觉得惹恼奥利维尔的并不是玛丽莲的方法演技。我觉得是他发现她身上那种淡淡的混乱特质让人抓狂。但话说回来，这也是她身上那种神奇之处：当他们——再次当他们看毛片
and they put the film together, her performance is transcendent and much, I think, much better than Olivier's. Well, Olivier says that himself. But she, I think, acts him off the screen. Well, he says that later on, he put on the film for friends thinking they would all laugh at it and laugh at her and he said by the time it was over you know it was very clear that she'd been by far the best person in it and um and he admits
并把电影剪辑到一起时，她的表演超凡脱俗，而且我认为比奥利维尔的表演好得多。嗯，奥利维尔自己也这么说。但我认为她的演技把奥利维尔压得黯然失色。嗯，他后来自己也说过，他放这部电影给朋友们看，以为大家会嘲笑它、嘲笑她，他说等放映结束时，你知道，很明显她才是里面表现最好的人，而且——
that himself to do him credit so i don't think it's yeah um there is definitely a degree of kind of auteur from him when she comes over this sort of American blonde bombshell. Ha ha ha. She's saying big words that she doesn't understand. But to do him credit, I think he came to recognize
为了保持客观，他自己也承认了这一点，所以我不认为——是的，嗯，当她这个美国金发性感尤物来到英国时，他身上确实带着某种程度的姿态。哈哈。她说一些她自己都不懂的大词。但平心而论，我觉得他后来还是意识到了
his own mistake. Anyway, she goes back to... Well, no, hold on, Dominic. Hold on. Hold on. Hold on.
自己的错误。不管怎样，她回到了——不，等等，多米尼克。等等。等等。等等。
Because also she meets the Queen. Born in the same year, of course, 1926. Born in the same year. And supposedly she
因为她还见到了女王。当然是同年出生，1926年。同年出生。而且据说
had a lesbian fling with Brigitte Bardot at the reception for the Queen. That's absolutely balderdash, isn't it? That's one of those stories that's completely made up. I know, but I just thought I'd put it out there. Yeah, I knew you'd love a story like that.
她在女王的招待会上和碧姬·芭铎（Brigitte Bardot）有过一段同性恋情。这完全是无稽之谈，对吧？这完全是那种凭空捏造的故事。我知道，但我只是想把它抛出来。是的，我知道你会喜欢这种故事。
No, not at all. But it's all about the intersection of royalty and Hollywood and French sophistication. And the intersection point makes a story like that irresistible so i think that that's kind of interesting demonstration of how when you have the ingredients people just can't resist mixing them all up and generating a fantastical concoction i just throw that out there fantastical concoction so by this point actually the funny thing is that by this point 1956 1957 i mean she's probably more famous than she's ever been. And yet you could argue that there were the shining exception of Some Like It Hot, the Billy Wilder film get bums on seats in American cinemas. And actually, Some Like It Hot is the only film that she has yet to make
不，完全不是。但这一切都关乎皇室、好莱坞与法国精致风情的交汇。而这种交汇点让这样一个故事变得让人无法抗拒，所以我认为这算是一个有趣的展示，展示了当把这些成分汇集在一起时，人们就是无法抗拒将它们全部混合并炮制出一个光怪陆离的虚构故事。我只是把它抛出来——一个光怪陆离的虚构故事。所以到这个时候，有趣的是，实际上到了这个节点，1956年、1957年，我的意思是她可能比以往任何时候都要出名。然而你可以说，除了《热情似火》（Some Like It Hot）这部比利·比利·怀尔德（Billy Wilder）的电影成功吸引美国观众买票入场这个闪亮的例外之外，事实上，《热情似火》是她至今拍摄的电影中，
that anybody ever watches today. I mean, that's pretty much right, isn't it? Yeah, I think so. She's got about six years to live. But actually, those six years are pretty unhappy years one way or another. I mean, she's becoming increasingly dependent on pills and drugs the lateness the endless demanding endless retakes you know it's actually a fairly it's it's a sort of you don't have to see it through the lens of her death and to you know with this sort of teleology
唯一一部今天还让人津津乐道的电影。我的意思是，这基本上是对的，对吧？是的，我想是的。她大概还有六年生命。但实际上，这六年不管怎么说都相当不快乐。我的意思是，她越来越依赖药丸和毒品，总是迟到、无休止地要求一遍又一遍地重拍，你知道，这实际上相当——这是一种——你不一定非得透过她死亡的视角，以这种带有宿命论的眼光去审视它——
knowing that the sort of her doom is fast approaching to see it as actually a pretty standard holly Hollywood story of somebody who's had this tremendous rise, this peak, and now the decline begins. Or do you think I'm being too harsh, Tom? No, I don't think so. She makes this film, The Misfits, that's been written by Arthur Miller. And it's a kind of pretentious Western, I guess would be the best way to describe it. And she doesn't really like it.
知道她的厄运正在迅速逼近，而是把它看作一个相当标准的好莱坞故事：某人经历了巨大的崛起和巅峰，而现在衰落开始了。还是你觉得我太苛刻了，汤姆？不，我不这么认为。她拍了这部电影《乱点鸳鸯谱》（The Misfits），剧本是阿瑟·米勒写的。我觉得最好的描述大概是一部矫揉造作的西部片。而且她其实并不喜欢它。
She doesn't like the script and she doesn't like the, because it's clearly it's Miller's portrayal of his wife and she doesn't like the portrayal. And we should say as well that while in England, she's supposedly seen a diary entry that miller had written um criticizing her which is conventionally cast as a kind of mortal blow to her relationship and and the misfits was kind of designed to be the film that would showcase her as a kind of great tragic actress and it doesn't really work and it's part of of the, it contributes to the disintegration of her marriage to Miller.
她不喜欢剧本，她也不喜欢——因为这显然是米勒对妻子的刻画，而她不喜欢这种刻画。我们还应该说，在英国期间，她据说看到了米勒写的一篇日记，里面批评了她，这在传统上被视为对他们关系的一记致命打击。《乱点鸳鸯谱》本来被设计成一部展示她作为伟大悲剧女演员风采的电影，但它并没有真正奏效，而且这是——它加速了她与米勒婚姻的解体。
And so they separate. And so she's back on her own again. Would you go so far as to say that she is, she doesn't like being alone? I mean, she's nervous of being alone. I think she's needy. I think most people say that she's quite a needy person, which is not unreasonable. I mean, there are lots of needy people. And I mean, to delve once more into the sort of murky waters of amateur psychology. is quite a needy person which is not unreasonable i mean there are lots of needy people and i mean
于是他们分居了。所以她又孤身一人了。你会不会觉得她——她不喜欢独自一人？我的意思是，她害怕孤独。我觉得她很有依赖心。我想大多数人都说她是一个挺有依赖心的人，这并不过分。我的意思是，有很多这样有依赖心的人；而且我的意思是，再次深入探讨业余心理学的那些浑水——
to delve once more into the sort of murky waters of amateur psychology yes well that's what i was worrying that you'd accuse me of doing but it's fine when i do it tom i mean well yes go ahead um no but i mean she's somebody who's had a troubled or or a background with a pretty high degree of instability so it makes sense that she would crave a degree of stability. And you're right, she's not good at being on her own. Her health is pretty awful. She's popping pills like nobody's business by this point. Yeah, and she suffers quite badly from endometriosis, for example.
她是一个挺有依赖心的人，这并不过分。我的意思是，有很多这样有依赖心的人；而且我的意思是，再次深入探讨业余心理学的那些浑水——
She's taking a lot of pills. Again, these things are not – because she dies in 1962, we read everything backwards so we say oh she's popping pills therefore she's on a downward spiral that will end in disaster but of course lots of people are taking a lot of pills barbiturates are very common in hollywood and in new york um at the turn of the 1960s so that doesn't make her tremendously unusual i would say no no but and and also you say that i mean after some like it hot her films slightly go off the boil but her ability to situate herself in the kind of the crosshairs
是的，好吧，这正是我担心你会指责我做的事，不过没关系，当我这么做的时候，汤姆，我的意思是——好吧，是的，请继续。嗯，但我的意思是，她是一个有着一段相当高度不稳定的坎坷童年或背景的人，所以她渴望某种程度的稳定性是合情合理的。你说得对，她不擅长独处。她的健康状况相当糟糕。到这个时候，她疯狂地吞服药丸。是的，而且她饱受子宫内膜异位症的折磨，比如说。
of american life remains unexampled so she becomes very close to uh to frank sinatra probably the the biggest name in music in the world at the time, and the Rat Pack, and of course, Rumored Affairs with Bobby Kennedy, the president of the United States, John F. Kennedy. Okay, so this obviously transforms her historical reputation, doesn't it? Her posthumous reputation. I mean, we see her entire life now through the lens of those Kennedy, supposed Kennedy relationships. Here's what I think about those. John F. Kennedy was a man who had an enormous number of affairs, whether he was, you know, people have different sort of theories about why actually, is it because he suffers from Addison's disease and his horrendous kind of health complaints, and
她吃了很多药。同样，这些事情并不是——因为她在1962年去世，我们把一切都倒推回去，所以我们说“哦，她在吃药，因此她正处于通往灾难的螺旋式下降中”，但当然，很多人都在吃很多药，巴比妥酸盐在20世纪60年代初的好莱坞和纽约非常普遍，所以我觉得这并不显得她有多么异常。不，不，而且——而且你说得对，在《热情似火》之后，她的电影稍微有点走下坡路，但她将自己置身于美国生活风口浪尖的能力依然无与伦比——
therefore he's trying to blot out the pain? Is it because has this kind of do I just say new year yes or is it just that he's you know an extremely good-looking kind of slightly oversexed sort of bloke in 1960s America Marilyn Monroe I think without any doubt had a liaison with him or multiple liaisons it almost certainly wasn wasn't a love affair. There's no reason to believe that it was. And there's no reason to believe that there's anything especially, actually, even that exciting about it. It's only a sort of prurient voyeurism that has elevated this into something. I don't think it's just voyeurism though, is it? It's the conspiracy theory. It's the sense that there are deep truths and the fact that she then dies. Yeah, I know. But I mean, Sarah Churchill is very good about this. She sort of says, that there are deep truths and the fact that she then dies yeah i know but i mean sarah churchill
所以她和弗兰克·辛纳屈（Frank Sinatra）——当时世界上音乐界最大牌的人物，以及鼠党（Rat Pack）变得非常亲密，当然，还有与美国总统约翰·F·肯尼迪的弟弟、鲍比·肯尼迪（Bobby Kennedy）的绯闻。好吧，所以这显然改变了她的历史声誉，不是吗？她的身后名。我的意思是，我们现在看待她的一生，都是通过那些肯尼迪、所谓的肯尼迪关系的视角。以下是我对这些事的看法：约翰·F·肯尼迪是一个有过大量婚外情的人，无论他是——你知道，人们对于原因有各种不同的理论，是因为他患有艾迪生病（Addison's disease）和可怕的健康问题，
is very good about this she sort of says maybe they were just having an affair because you know they quite fancied each other and you know saw each other a few times and and that's an end to it that's not unheard of in the history of the human race of course but but because she's having an affair with kennedy and with sinatra and so not you know she goes having an affair with Kennedy and with Sinatra, and she goes to hang out with Sinatra in places that are clearly funded by the mafia. So Sinatra gives her a dog and she calls it Math after the mafia. So she's very much aware of all this. So she is an intersection point between the mafia and JFK. And that, I think, is why it's become part of the broader narrative
因此他试图借此抹去痛苦？是因为——等等，我是不是刚说了“新年”？是的——还是说他只是——你知道的，20世纪60年代美国一个长相极佳、荷尔蒙略微过剩的家伙？玛丽莲·梦露，我认为毫无疑问她与他有过一次或多次私情，但几乎肯定不是一段恋爱关系。没有任何理由相信那是。也没有理由相信其中有什么特别令人激动的成分。只是一种好色的偷窥癖才把这变成了一件大事。不过我觉得这不仅仅是偷窥癖，对吧？这是阴谋论。那种认为其中隐藏着深刻真相的感觉，以及她随后来死去的事实。是的，我知道。不过——萨拉·丘奇韦尔（Sarah Churchill）对此有很好的看法，她某种程度上说——隐藏着深刻真相的感觉，以及她随后来死去的事实，是的，我知道。不过——萨拉·丘奇韦尔
generated by Kennedy's assassination the year after Marilyn's death. And what about Bobby Kennedy? I've always found that story a tiny bit more implausible, actually. It's actually the more common one that people tell. So people get very excited about the thought that she had an affair with the Attorney General, Robert Kennedy. And, in fact, you will often read in this sort of more exploitative biographies that they were this tremendous love affair and they were this sort of couple that was separated by fate and all this
对此有很好的看法，她某种程度上说，也许他们只是在谈恋爱，因为——你知道，他们挺看上彼此的，你知道，见了面好几次，事情也就这样结束了。在人类历史这并不闻所未闻，当然。但是——因为她和肯尼迪以及辛纳屈都有染，所以——你知道，她去和辛纳屈厮混的地方显然有黑手党的资金支持。所以辛纳屈送了她一只狗，她把它叫做“Maf”（黑手党缩写）。所以她对这一切非常清楚。因此她是黑手党和肯尼迪之间的交汇点。而我认为，这就是为什么它成了由肯尼迪在玛丽莲死后次年被刺杀所引发的宏大叙事的一部分。那鲍比·肯尼迪呢？我一直觉得那个故事其实稍微更不可信一点。这其实是人们讲述得更普遍的版本。所以人们对她与总检察长罗伯特·肯尼迪（Robert Kennedy）有染的想法感到非常兴奋，事实上，你经常会在这种比较剥削性的传记中读到，他们曾有过一段轰轰烈烈的爱情，他们是那种被命运拆散的情侣之类的话。
kind of thing. I mean, you could hardly think of two more different personalities than Robert Kennedy and Marilyn Monroe. Robert Kennedy was a very controlled, intense, serious kind of man, who was his brother's hatchet man, actually, this time in his career, as sort of in JFK's campaign in 1960, and then as his attorney general. Robert Kennedy also had a colossal amount of children within a very short period of time, because he's a very kind of serious Catholic. So he's got about 27 kids. I mean, just a preposterous number of children. I don't know i think the the trouble the thing about the affair with robert kennedy is there is literally no evidence at all so all
我的意思是，你很难想象出比罗伯特·肯尼迪和玛丽莲·梦露性格更迥异的两个人了。罗伯特·肯尼迪是一个极具控制欲、紧张、严肃的人，在他人生的这个阶段，他实际上是他兄长的冷面杀手，比如在JFK 1960年的竞选活动中，以及后来担任总检察长期间。罗伯特·肯尼迪在很短的时间内还生了巨量的孩子，因为他是一个非常虔诚的天主教徒。所以他有大约27个孩子。我的意思是，孩子的数量简直荒谬。我不觉得——我觉得关于罗伯特·肯尼迪的绯闻的问题在于，字面意义上没有任何证据，所以所有的
there is is gossip that is so that's constantly sort of you know recirculated and all the different biographies but there's no kind of documentary evidence that they had this relationship it's just that pure supposition but but the same is true of roswell of course well yeah yes it's about the same level as roswell i think it's fair to say tom i think that's a very good comparison yeah yeah and so that's that this is the background kennedy's sinatra that is providing the context for the years the months the days that leads up to her death. Right. I mean, the big thing that happens in the run up to her death that everybody will remember is she sings happy birthday to Kennedy at Madison Square Garden. His birthday, he has this sort of premature birthday celebration.
东西都只是八卦，这些八卦在不同的传记中被不断地重新炒作，但并没有任何文献证据表明他们有过这种关系，这纯粹是无端臆测——但罗斯威尔事件也是如此，当然。好吧，是的，这大概和罗斯威尔处于同一水平，我觉得这样说很公平，汤姆，我觉得这是一个很好的比喻，是的，是的。所以这就是背景——肯尼迪、辛纳屈，它们为通往她死亡的那些年、那些月、那些天提供了语境。没错。在她的死前发生的一件每个人都会记住的大事，就是她在麦迪逊广场花园为肯尼迪唱生日歌。他的生日，他举办了这种提前的生日庆祝活动。
And I think it's the 19th of May, 1962. And she is squeezed into this incredibly sort of sexy figure hugging-hugging dress and she sings in a very sort of breathy kind of way breathy exactly it was a breathy way i mean it's just a very um this sort of you know overtly sexualized way happy birthday mr president and for everybody in the know i mean it's they think it think it's quite close to the bone. It's quite on the nose. It's quite funny that she's almost publicly flaunting the fact that they've had a relationship.
我想那是1962年5月19日。她被塞进那件极其性感、紧贴身体的礼服里，她用一种非常气音式的方式歌唱——气音，没错，就是用气音，我的意思是，这只是一种非常——这种你知道的、赤裸裸的性化方式，“祝你生日快乐，总统先生”。对于所有知情的人来说，我的意思是，他们觉得这有点过于露骨了。有点直白。她几乎是在公开炫耀他们曾有过关系，这挺搞笑的。
But again, had she not died several months later, and had he then not died and had a second term as president and been embroiled in Vietnam, would this be this sort of doomed moment i mean obviously it wouldn't be but but it did and so it is i mean yes fair enough fair enough that's that's the whole point i mean the point entirely taken but she does die and she kind of dies she dies at the age of 36 the same age that byron died um and and it's that that enables her to you know she doesn't grow old but but what don't you think that what you think of the death colors the entire story of course absolutely you back project it absolutely completely you back project the
但话说回来，如果她没有几个月后死去，如果他后来没有遇刺身亡、没有开启第二任期并深陷越南泥潭，这会不会成为那种命中注定的时刻——我的意思是，显然不会，但事实是它发生了，所以它就是了。我的意思是，好吧，没关系，没关系，这正是关键所在，我的意思是，完全同意这个观点。但她确实死了，而且她死的时候——她死时36岁，和拜伦去世时的年龄一样——正是这一点让她得以——你知道的，她没有变老。难道你不认为，你对她之死的看法给整个故事蒙上了色彩吗？当然，绝对是的。你完全把它倒推回去了，
whole thing or if you think that she committed suicide because she's so miserable and unhappy of course she's been a victim all her life she's being murdered by by bobby kennedy or jfk or the mafia or i mean of course absolutely i mean you but listeners will not be surprised that i do not think she was murdered by the mafia do you think it was bobby kennedy then i don't think she's murdered by the kennedys donald spoto one of her biographers, has a complicated theory about that basically is that it boils down to it being an accident. Sarah Churchwell, I think, thinks it was probably an accident. That seems as likely as anything to me. I mean, the truth is, again, we cannot know. So anybody who tells you they know is wrong, is just wrong, because we
你把整件事完全倒推回去了。或者如果你认为她自杀是因为她太痛苦、太不幸，当然，她一生都是受害者；或者她是被鲍比·肯尼迪、JFK或黑手党谋杀的——我的意思是，当然，绝对是的，我的意思是，听众们不会惊讶于我认为她不是被黑手党谋杀的。你觉得那是鲍比·肯尼迪干的吗？我不认为她是死于肯尼迪家族之手。唐纳德·斯波托（Donald Spoto），她的传记作家之一，对此有一个复杂的理论，基本上归结为这是一场意外。萨拉·丘奇韦尔，我想，认为这可能是一场意外。这在我看来和任何说法一样有可能。我的意思是，事实是，再次强调，我们无法得知。所以任何告诉你他知道的人都是错的，就是错的，因为我们
cannot know. But i think the most likely thing is that she's taking an awful lot of pills of various kinds and she probably takes an accidental overdose i mean again it's hardly uncommon among hollywood film stars rock stars and so on of the 1960s and 1970s is it i mean but i said so people compare her to Elvis or to Jim Morrison or whatever, you know, famous people who die young. But I think that she's much better thought of as part of that nexus of weird conspiracy. So I mentioned Roswell. I think it's not. I think she has become part of that kind of industry of conspiracy theories. But because she, you know, she, it's not just that she was intimate with key, key, you know,
无法得知。但我认为最有可能的是，她服用了大量各种各样的药丸，她可能是不小心过量了。我的意思是，话说回来，这在1960年代和1970年代的好莱坞影星、摇滚巨星等等之中难道不是很常见吗？我的意思是，人们拿她和埃尔维斯（Elvis）或吉姆·莫里森（Jim Morrison）或诸如此类英年早逝的名人作比较。但我认为，最好把她看作那种离奇阴谋网络的一部分。所以我提到了罗斯威尔。我觉得不仅如此。我觉得她已经成为了那种阴谋论产业的一部分。但因为她——你知道，她——不仅因为她与核心人物关系亲密——
Arthur Miller, Joe DiMaggio, the Kennedys, Frank Sinatra. I mean, these are titanic figures in the culture of mid-century America. But also that she is so beautiful and she dies young. And I think I'm right that the first of the screen prints that Warhol does is of Marilyn. So she sets the blazes the path for all the other Chairman Mao's and Elizabeth II and all the other ones that he'll go on to do. Sarah Churchill is brilliant on this, on how the moment she dies and maybe even before she's died the myth is cannibalizing her the real marilyn and and so it has always done and and i think that the degree you know the the fact that um someone can be cannibalized to the degree that she has been tells us a lot about the evolution of
阿瑟·米勒、乔·迪马吉奥、肯尼迪家族、弗兰克·辛纳屈。我的意思是，这些都是世纪中期美国文化中的泰斗级人物。而且还因为她如此美丽却又英年早逝。我想我没记错的话，沃霍尔创作的第一幅丝网版画就是玛丽莲。所以她为他以后要创作的所有毛主席像、伊丽莎白二世以及其他所有的版画开辟了道路。萨拉·丘奇韦尔在这方面的论述非常精彩，谈到在她死的那一刻，甚至在她死之前，神话就已经在吞噬真正的玛丽莲了，而且一直如此。并且我认为，某种程度上——
of popular culture and media over the decades that have followed her death, don't you think? I think that's true. I think the timing is really important. So she dies in 1962, in the summer of 1962. Kennedy dies in the autumn of 1963. So they're quite compressed. Robert Kennedy dies in 1968, the same year as Martin Luther King.
一个人能被吞噬到她这种程度，这说明了在她死后的几十年里，大众文化和媒体的演变，你不觉得吗？我觉得是这样的。我觉得时机非常重要。所以她死于1962年，1962年的夏天。肯尼迪死于1963年的秋天。所以这两个时间非常紧凑。罗伯特·肯尼迪死于1968年，与马丁·路德·金（Martin Luther King）同年。
Both Marilyn Monroe and John F kennedy died before the 60s took you know what in sort of narrative terms are their sort of dark downward turn so they both die before the war in vietnam really comes to dominate the headlines they die before the civil rights movement before the sort of the the marches and the martyrdom give way to kind of to the riots in 1967, 68. Yeah, and assassinations until violence comes to dominate the headlines, rather than, let's say, justice, if you like. So I think... Do you think that that gets back projected, the sense that there is a kind of violence within American public life that devours its own. I mean, I think to some degree, to some degree, I suppose you could say that violence was always there,
玛丽莲·梦露和约翰·F·肯尼迪都在20世纪60年代经历（用叙事的话说）他们黑暗的急转直下之前去世。所以他们都在越战真正主导新闻头条之前去世，都在民权运动、游行和殉道演变成1967、1968年骚乱之前去世。是的，还有暗杀事件，直到暴力开始主导新闻头条，而不是——比方说，如果你愿意的话——正义。所以我觉得……你觉得这是一种倒推吗，那种认为美国公众生活中存在一种吞噬自身的暴力的感觉？我的意思是，在某种程度上，在某种程度上，我想你可以说这种暴力一直都在，
simmering below the surface. But I think you're right that these are sort of, these now in the sort of standard pop cultural narrative become kind of great harbingers of doom, don't they? The death of Marilyn Monroe and the death of John F. Kennedy. So if Marilyn had lived, if it was an accident and the accident had not happened, what would her life have looked like in the later 1960s and 1970s? She would presumably have done other films, but not probably very successful films. She would have been yesterday's woman. She'd have been left behind by, I don't know, Faye Dunaway or younger kind of stars
在表面下暗流涌动。但我认为你说得对，在标准流行文化叙事中，这些现在都成了某种巨大的厄运先兆，对吧？玛丽莲·梦露之死和约翰·F·肯尼迪之死。所以如果玛丽莲活下来了，如果那是一场意外而意外没有发生，她在20世纪60年代后期和1970年代的生活会是什么样子？她大概会拍其他电影，但可能不会是非常成功的电影。她会成为昨日黄花。她会被——我不知道，被费·唐纳薇（Faye Dunaway）或具有截然不同性吸引力形象的年轻明星所抛在身后。
who were very different kind of image of sexuality. Well, I think you look at Elizabeth Taylor, don't you think? Yeah, exactly, Elizabeth Taylor. So what happens to Elizabeth Taylor would have been her, Marilyn's parabola, I guess. Yeah. I mean, this may annoy some listeners who are very attached to Marilyn Monroe, but you can imagine the future in which she'd,
好吧，我觉得你看伊丽莎白·泰勒（Elizabeth Taylor）就知道了，你不觉得吗？是的，没错，伊丽莎白·泰勒。所以伊丽莎白·泰勒的遭遇，就会是她、玛丽莲的轨迹，我猜。是的。我的意思是，这可能会惹恼一些对玛丽莲·梦露非常依恋的听众，但你可以想象这样一种未来：
she's walking around in 1972 and it's, she's kind of blousy. There's a lot of booze. She hasn't made a film in five years. Directors say she's impossible to work with. You know, she's thrown off a flight. The story kind of writes itself.
她在1972年四处走动，显得有些臃肿。喝了很多酒。她已经五年没拍过电影了。导演们说她根本无法合作。你知道的，她被赶下了飞机。这个故事简直不言自明。
She's got off with Richard Nixon at last. Yes. The couple that was meant to be. Yeah, I mean, I think because she's cut down when she is in 1962, she becomes the symbol of a kind of lost innocence, I suppose, doesn't she? Because, of course, this is the point up to the 1960s, sexuality and sort of sex is framed very much in terms of kind of increasing availability and visibility and so on. And this sort of, there's no sense or very much less of a sense of it being politically conflicted as it becomes later in the 1960s and then the 1970s. So you talked earlier
她终于和理查德·尼克松勾搭上了。是的。本该天生一对的情侣。是的，我的意思是，我觉得由于她在1962年盛年陨落，她成了某种失落纯真的象征，对吧？因为，当然，这是直到20世纪60年代之前的一点，性与某种程度的性观念在很大程度上被构建为一种日益普及和可见的状态，等等。并且这种——没有感觉到，或者极少感觉到它像20世纪60年代后期和1970年代那样充满政治冲突。所以你刚才谈到
about her as a sort of feminist figure, but really that sort of 60s feminism has yet to get underway by the time of her death. And it's interesting to think about how she would be perceived. How would she have adapted to that world? Would she have continued to kind of improve herself, as it were, and to sort of ride the wave? Or would she have been left behind? Would she have been a relic of a sort of slightly discredited, shop-soiled kind of 50s world? Well, I suppose the brutal truth is that people probably wouldn't care what she thought, actually. Do people care what Elizabeth Taylor thought?
她是一个某种程度上的女权主义者，但实际上，到她去世时，那种60年代的女权主义甚至还没有真正拉开帷幕。思考她会被如何感知是一件很有趣的事。她会如何适应那个世界？她会继续某种程度上的自我完善，并乘风破浪吗？还是会被时代抛弃？她会成为一个略显名誉扫地、沾满灰尘的50年代世界的遗老吗？好吧，我想残酷的真相是，人们可能根本不在乎她怎么想，真的。人们会在乎伊丽莎白·泰勒怎么想吗？
Probably not. The weird thing is that she wouldn't be the icon that she is now, right? I mean, if the blousiness and the being kicked off Concord had happened in 1976, you know, Gap or, I mean, Gap used her image in the 1990s. Would they have used it in the 1990s no of course they wouldn't because they don't use elizabeth taylor now no i agree but that's i mean that and so that's why she was so you know why the um candle in the wind could so readily be adapted by elton john to the death of diana as well i mean i think in some ways the funny thing about
大概不会。奇怪的是，她不会成为现在的那个偶像，对吧？我的意思是，如果那种臃肿感和被赶出协和号飞机的事情发生在1976年，你知道的，Gap——我的意思是，Gap在20世纪90年代用了她的形象。他们会在90年代使用它吗？不，当然不会，因为他们现在也不会用伊丽莎白·泰勒。不，我同意，但这就是——我的意思是，这就是为什么她如此——你知道，为什么埃尔顿·约翰（Elton John）的《风中之烛》（Candle in the Wind）能如此轻易地被改编用来悼念戴安娜的死。我的意思是，我觉得在某种程度上，玛丽莲·梦露有趣的地方在于，
marilyn munro is that she's become so confused with the Kennedy story, hasn't she? Oh, with the Kennedy story. With Diana as well, yeah. Do you know, I mean, she's, well, I mean, that's the interesting thing about Marilyn Monroe, that we could talk for sort of three hours
她已经变得和肯尼迪的故事高度混淆了，不是吗？哦，和肯尼迪的故事。还有和戴安娜的故事，是的。你知道，我的意思是，她——好吧，我的意思是，这正是玛丽莲·梦露有趣的地方，我们可以聊上大约三个小时，
and there are lots of different kind of angles into the story. But actually the funny thing is, what is so often missing, what we struggle to get a sense of is actually the woman herself, isn't it? Because a lot of what we've talked about in this podcast has been about iconography, about symbolism. But the actual, the reality of the woman is really hard to get at, I think.
而且切入这个故事的角度有很多种。但实际上有趣的是，往往缺失的是什么，我们努力去捕捉的感觉，实际上是她作为女性本身的真实面貌，对吧？因为我们在本播客中讨论的很多内容都是关于图像学、关于象征主义。但这位女性的实际现实，是极其难以触及的，我觉得。
Well, I called her lovable. Every biography of her I've read, whenever she's allowed to speak in her own voice, she comes across as very smart, very funny, very likable. I mean, clearly quite difficult. I mean, she was a Hollywood diva. But I think the most kind of personally attractive of all Hollywood stars, all the big Hollywood stars. You think so? I do. Yeah, I do.
好吧，我称她为可爱。我读过的每一本关于她的传记中，每当她被允许用自己的声音说话时，她都显得非常聪明、非常风趣、非常讨人喜欢。我的意思是，显然也相当难搞。我的意思是，她是一个好莱坞巨星。但我认为她是所有好莱坞明星、所有大好莱坞明星中最具有个人吸引力的一位。你这么认为吗？我是这么觉得。是的，我是这么觉得。
You'd rather go for dinner with Marilyn Monroe than with Grace Kelly, Tom? I think I probably would, yeah. Okay. Well, on that, you and I would differ. So I suppose, Dominic, I mean, essentially, you know, if we want to sum up what this episode's been about, in a very real sense, she was like a candle in the wind. Is that what you'd say? Oh, Tom, that's painful. That's painful. I think she's a fascinating... She's an example of the challenges of biography on the one hand, and trying to make sense to fit into a historical narrative, the life of a complicated individual. But she's also a brilliant way to talk about 50s and 60s America. And actually,
宁愿和玛丽莲·梦露共进晚餐，也不愿和格蕾丝·凯利（Grace Kelly）共进晚餐吗，汤姆？我想我大概会吧，是的。好吧。关于这一点，你和我意见不一。所以我想，多米尼克，我的意思是，本质上，你知道的，如果我们想总结这一期节目讲了什么，从一个非常现实的意义上来说，她就像风中的蜡烛。你会这么说吗？哦，汤姆，这太伤人了。这太伤人了。我觉得她是一个迷人的——一方面，她是传记写作挑战的例子，试图在一个历史叙事中赋予一个复杂个体的生命以意义。但她也是讨论50年代和60年代美国的绝佳切入点。而且事实上，
we will be coming back almost exactly a year from now. So that's a long time for listeners to wait, but we will be finally returning to the subject of the Kennedy assassination in won't we, in 2023 for the anniversary. And I'm really looking forward to that because we can go into it in depth and talk about all the conspiracy theories. All of you who listen, who espouse one particular theory or other, you'll all find something to offend you and to, as we dismiss all the theories. As we reveal the truth.
我们将在大约一年后的今天回归。所以听众们还要等很长时间，但我们最终将在2023年为了纪念周年而回到肯尼迪遇刺这个主题上来，不是吗？我真的很期待这一点，因为我们可以深入探讨并讨论所有的阴谋论。你们所有收听节目的人，无论你们信奉哪一种特定的理论，你们都会找到冒犯你们的东西，正如我们将驳斥所有的理论一样。正如我们将揭示真相一样。
And we reveal the real truth. Frank Sinatra killing JFK because he'd murdered Marilyn. The truth will out. The truth is out there and we will reveal it. Thanks very much for listening. Bye-bye. Bye-bye. Thanks for listening to The Rest Is History. For bonus episodes, early access, ad-free listening and access to our chat community, please sign up at restishistorypod.com. That's restishistorypod.com. I'm Marina Hyde.
而我们将揭示真正的真相。弗兰克·辛纳屈因为肯尼迪谋杀了玛丽莲而杀了他。真相终将大白。真相就在那里，我们将把它揭晓。非常感谢收听。再见。再见。感谢收听《历史其余部分》（The Rest Is History）。想要收听独家节目、提前点播、无广告收听以及加入我们的聊天社区，请在 restishistorypod.com 注册。网址是 restishistorypod.com。我是玛丽娜·海德（Marina Hyde）。
And I'm Richard Osman. And together we host The Rest Is Entertainment. It's your weekly fix of entertainment news, reviews, splash of showbiz gossip. And on our Q&A, we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works. We have just launched our Members Club. If you want ad-free listening, bonus episodes and early access to live tickets, head to therestisentertainment.com. That's therestisentertainment.com. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我是理查德·奥斯曼（Richard Osman）。我们共同主持《娱乐其余部分》（The Rest Is Entertainment）。这是你每周获取娱乐新闻、评论和八卦的绝佳去处。在我们的问答环节中，我们将揭开娱乐业的神秘面纱，告诉你这一切是如何运作的。我们刚刚推出了会员俱乐部。如果你想要无广告收听、独家节目和优先购买现场门票的权利，请访问 therestisentertainment.com。网址是 therestisentertainment.com。本集目前还没有评论。点击剧本中的任意句子即可发表评论。